[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote webinar titled designing machine
learning processes for Equitable Health
Systems this webinar is a part of the
11th annuals event in the Neuroscience
virtual event series I am Morgan
Sterling of labroots and I will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab Roots now let's get started before
we begin I would like to remind everyone
that this is an event that is
interactive we do encourage you to First
participate by communicating with other
attendees using our live chat feature
during the
presentation
live chat located at the left of your
screen you can also participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click submit we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of our
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
help desk button located at the top of
your screen within the navigation bar or
from the lobby I now present today's
speaker marazia gimi PhD assistant
professor electrical engineering and
Computer Science Institute for medical
engineering and science MIT for a
complete biography on our speakers
please visit the presenter tab from the
menu at the left of your screen Dr gasmi
you may now be begin your
presentation hi everyone uh today I'm
going to talk to you about about
designing machine learning processes for
Equitable Health
Systems um and the first thing that I'd
like to have you keep in mind is that
our goal is to create actionable
insights in human health um my lab is
the healthy machine learning Lab at
MIT um and I'm going to give you some
examples of what you can do when you do
machine learning in health so let's say
we have a patient like suana who's
having trouble breathing we'd like to
improve treatment choices with data and
learning so you can take data from a
hospital as you can see it might look
like this patient data uh progresses
over time we have vitals and Labs that
are evolving over the course of a day
and then we play a game where we want to
do real-time prediction of something the
need for a drug the onset of mortality
the development of some condition by
some Gap time before the doctor would
have detected those things uh were
needed or would have occurred and I say
real time in quotes because this is not
not a real system uh in a real Hospital
we're taking past data and we're
pretending that the model is seeing it
in real time and then importantly we
score the model we give it feedback on
how well it's doing based on whether it
gets the actions of the doctor right and
so it gets a reward for doing uh what
the doctor would have done predicting
early that you would have needed
something and it gets a penalty for not
doing what the doctor did now uh what we
found is that you can do really
interesting uh machine learning methods
now that we have large amounts of data
so as an example this is from a few
years ago we took over 30,000 ICU
patient records from the mimic 3
database this included static variables
that don't change over the course of a
stay time varying vitals and labs and
also all of the patients notes which you
can pre-process using topic models
Transformers or GPT style
models and then we trained neural
networks to predict a set of different
tasks and so not just one thing but
invasive and non-invasive ventilation
the need for a vasopressor and different
kinds of fluid boluses and we found that
using this kind of data along with
neural networks we were able to increase
our performance or Au where higher is
better for uh all of these different
kinds of interventions even those that
have the lowest proportions of examples
so they're generally a harder task but
we're not the only lab that does this uh
as you may know this is a pretty big
field um and machine learning for health
actually has a uh really large uh set of
labs around the world that are producing
great papers just like this one and so
this is a table showing uh a set of
cases where clinical AI was benchmarked
to perform at or above humans in a
health care task and this is across a
range of tasks in the human lifespan uh
and you'll notice that here for each of
these tasks there's a sample size n that
you know we used 30,000 people um but
this can range from a few hundred to
several hundred thousand and they're
also reporting the same number that we
reported the Au where higher is better
and they're reporting one number just
like we did um and so this is the point
where uh we ask you uh audience would
you want these wonderful models that
have been benchmarked to perform at or
above humans to work on you let's say
you go to the emergency room and um you
have a a cough you don't know if you
have pneumonia they do a chest x-ray you
can wait three hours for a doctor to
look at your chest x-ray because the
emergency department is backed up or
right now they could have an AI that's
been benchmarked on over 700,000 chest
x-rays and performs just as well um with
this Au metric as a doctor look at it
and determine if you're healthy and can
go home no pneumonia we don't need to
see you
further um and the question is which
would you choose would you wait three
hours for the doctor or would you take
this um equivalent cleared uh AI model
and uh the answer that I often get from
students here uh depends a little bit on
what their experiences have been with a
Health Care system because some people
say well of course it performs just as
well as a doctor that's great and then
some people say well but that number is
one number it's an average across all
people and you're scoring these machine
learning models on whether they behave
just like doctors and what if I've had
some bad experiences with doctors what
if I don't want to have the experience
that I had with my last medical visit
what if there was an error what if there
was bias and so the issue here is right
now when we train state-of-the-art
machine learning models they reproduce
healthc care as it stands now not as we
would desire it to
be and so as we go through the rest of
this uh presentation one thing I also
want you to keep in mind is that
everything I talk about relies on having
uh data and data from human bodies or
embodied data and this can be a really
powerful force for good and entities
like the NIH um uh physionet Nightingale
uh the olist data set there are many uh
nonprofit and govern nonprofit and
governmental organizations that are
working hard to ensure that we have
enough diverse data sets for research
use um and not data that's held only in
the hands of private uh companies or
organizations for the development of
products that will be sold back to
populations because if we want AI to
improve science and address medical harm
we really need to have data that's
available um and health is really
lagging other machine learning subfields
in data and code release in terms of
reproducibility and primarily where we
lag other General machine learning
Fields but also vision and natural
language processing specifically is in
these data releases and that means that
we disproportionately can't reproduce
other people's results because there's
no way to get access to their data even
when it's deidentified uh and there's
also no way to therefore leverage
multiple data sets because people won't
give you access to the underlying
data so let's go back to that example I
talked about um and let's think about Su
in the emergency room um maybe she has
pneumonia she has a chest X-ray let's
think about whether she wants this model
to work on her or whether she's going to
wait three hours so uh we actually did
this experiment we took the three large
test x-ray data sets that are publicly
available in the United States that's
over 700,000 images so good sample size
we trained a denet that's a kind of
convolutional neural network to predict
a no finding label that means the model
says the patient is healthy you don't
have have pneumonia you can go
home and we're going to compare the
false positive rate of this
state-of-the-art model that performs
best on average in different
subpopulations and we're going to call
differences uh in false positive rate
differences in the models under
diagnosis rate why because if you
falsely positively say the person's
healthy and can go home it means they
actually had a condition and you should
have seen them but you said they're
healthy and they were
underdiagnosed um and you can imagine if
you deployed a model that had a higher
underdiagnosis rate in one subpopulation
like female patients it would lead to a
higher rate of no treatment for patients
who actually needed it so we uh do this
we train this model um there's a uh
paper that we published a couple years
ago on it we find that the state of the
art model has the largest underdiagnosis
rate in female patients young patients
black patients and patients on Medicaid
insurance and you have much uh larger uh
under diagnosis rates in aggregate uh or
in uh specific groups uh that are
minorities within an aggregated group so
Black Or Hispanic female patients for
example are under diagnosed more than
white female patients or than just
female
patients and you might say as One
reviewer did okay that's fine why don't
you just audit models as uh we did here
in an early paper on algorithmic
fairness and health um and then show us
what the differential rates are and then
we can make a clinical uh decision about
what differences are tolerable by
certain factors for example race
ethnicity Insurance type or gender um
but this can get very tricky uh when
we're using complex models and might not
have access to um a complete
understanding of what the data it was
trained on is so let's take a um a
language model maybe you've heard of
chat GPT uh large language model that's
trained on billions and billions of
examples let's not use chat gbt because
that's trained on general purpose um
data let's take cybert and cybert is
trained on scientific articles and
abstracts right so um in theory uh maybe
less likely to espouse some of the
biases that we've seen um other general
purpose large language models have let's
take a sentence from a real medical note
blank patient became belligerent and
violent and was sent to fill in the
blank and let's take a use case that I
happen to know uh Chad GPT is being
proposed for right now completing the
blank in a uh Medical record just adding
to the note um because the doctor's done
most of it but we just want to finish it
out and uh let's ask CH GPT or the
equivalent here cybert what would happen
if we had a Caucasian patient or a white
patient that belligerent in that is
belligerant and violent um and cyber
here fills in the blank with they are
sent to the hospital that medical notes
done um if we have an African
African-American or black patient that
became belligerent and violent cybert
fills that out with sent to prison
and uh maybe this is you know something
that uh we could have detected um if we
looked for it ahead of time this one
specific case because I did look for it
and I did find it uh but there's a
plethora of these examples that have
been learned in this case just from you
know scientific abstracts from you know
published papers um not from the
internet at large um that we won't be
able to pre-audit for and so it's really
careful that we understand that while
our data can't be perfect it's very
important that we get it to be um as uh
balanced and as Fair as possible we've
done experiments also um where we've
tried to look at what happens if we have
bias data that we learn an embedding on
so something like a chat GPT or a cyber
and then later you know we saved this
embedded model that was trained on
billions and billions of examples uh but
biased data and then we have perfectly
Fair data now Downstream that we've
collected and we want to just project it
onto this representation we've learned
onto this ball and classify it having
perfectly Fair data Downstream and
projecting it onto an embedding a model
you learned from biased data retains the
bias uh of the original data set and so
it's not something that we can just say
later we'll have perfect data later
we'll be able to debias this um the
effects of biasing are something we have
to be aware of attempt to deal with
now and bias is a strong part of the
clinical landscape uh let's be super
clear here I am not suggesting that uh
the robots are coming to get us because
they hate us AI is not out to get humans
by default AI is out to get the humans
that it's noticed um humans are out to
get and so if you have AI That's trained
on medical data it's not going to
operate as your best doctor uh does on a
perfect day it will operate how doctors
tend to operate in
general Pop Quiz let's see how bad this
could get this is a medical note that I
redacted uh the patient's self-reported
race from it's a nursing progress note
for a specific patient can you tell what
this patient's self-reported race would
have
been probably not because all the
doctors that we tested couldn't uh but
the model
could and the model here is using
proxies or hidden associations that it's
learned over large amounts of data that
seem sort of reasonable right this is a
statistical bias not maybe a uh societal
bias it's learned that in the Northeast
specifically which is where this model
was trained uh the patients who seem to
be on dialysis and have hypertension are
uh self-reporting the race of black or
African-American um but that's not all
that it's using and so we looked at two
different data sets one in New York and
one in Boston
and uh we found that you know this is a
a corpus of over um three million notes
uh and almost uh 60,000 patients we
found that uh even very simple models
things like logistic regression can do
this really well um but more complex
models uh like these Transformer based
models that I mentioned do it even
better and ensembles that use multiple
uh views of the model do best and some
of the things it's using are fine right
again these are are maybe statistical
biases that it's noticed like there are
certain comorbidities in specific
patient populations and so we would say
maybe that guess that proxy is fine but
other things it's using are a little bit
more problematic so for example we found
that if you talk about skin at
all any skin-based presentation of
illness the model knows that the patient
is white uh because
disproportionately skin-based
presentation of illness is only noted in
lighter skinn patients and uh we also
found that if you use um you know
certain terminology about a patient's
family or if you describe patient
families as being difficult or the
patient themselves as being difficult uh
the model knows that those patients are
disproportionately black and so these
are associations that uh maybe uh we
found uh clinicians were not able to
pick up within these redacted notes but
the model seeing millions and millions
of examples of this can tell and so this
is problematic because if a model can
tell something so perfectly from looking
at the notes clearly there's a bias in
the generative process uh that we
wouldn't want
replicated by for example a Model A
large language model that was generating
infilling completing
notes second Pop Quiz a little bit
harder what about this patient can you
tell if this patient's self-reported
race would be black or
white and uh you know maybe you can
think about in the prior example uh the
generative process that would have led
to BU right like I tend to have a bias
against for example African-American
families and so I'll write difficult
disproportionately more often even when
the behavior is the same and so the
model's able to tell
that what's happening
here and so we find that it's actually
very easy uh for models and uh
impossible for Radiologists to tell
somebody self-reported Race using
Medical Imaging as input and so um what
are some of the proxies the model could
be using here obvious proxies we asked
um a set of Radiologists to give us a
fud to test it's not body mass index
it's not breast density it's not bone
density and it's not disease
distribution um there is frequency
information so high frequency
information mostly but if you put a band
pass filter which only allows certain uh
frequencies of the image uh through to
the model on these chest x-rays you can
still tell what somebody self-reported
race would be even when the image
doesn't really look like a chest x-ray
anymore and so I want to be really clear
it's not as if we're saying that
somebody's you know race is a is a
biological you know certainty and you
know uh black people look this way and
it's obvious this is self-reported race
which does uh not especially in
heterogeneous populations that
self-report African-American or white
race correspond to a specific genetic
ancestry um here what we think is
happening is in some part due to the
calibration of medical devices right
where you know this is actually an image
device where um you know much like um
commercial cameras which are not well
calibrated for darker skin um and pulse
oximeters which famously uh in the
recent FDA hearing uh do not work
equally well on darker skinned
individuals we see that there are subtle
differences in the way that a lot of
medical devices work uh for people uh
who have different levels of melanation
here we we think uh is happening and
that is in our data and if we don't
account for the fact that notes look
different when they are generated about
different people that devices report
data differently when it comes from
different people models will just
automate and extend those existing
gaps can we fix gaps with explanations
this is my uh favorite least favorite
question I think it I think it's
favorite Le's favorite because this is
an obvious question that I I think is a
go-to for all of us because uh as humans
we like explanations and we post ha talk
explain our own our own behaviors uh all
the time why did you buy that brand well
because it's better uh but probably just
because it was brighter or advertised
better um and so we wanted to look at
what happens when we use some of these
state-of-the-art post Haw explanation
methods that have been proposed to um
make models more trustworthy in high
stake settings like Health um I often
see these proposed when somebody uses a
blackbox model and then a reviewer says
Ah but you know to really make it
trustworthy and fair you should explain
it so we know what's going on so we took
the most uh popular and common blackbox
uh explanation methods these are both uh
local explanation meth methods like lime
and Shop lime has been cited over 8,000
times it's very popular it only came out
like I don't know seven years ago it it
was not that long ago so these are very
common things to do um and then Global
explanation methods as as well and uh
we're going to see what happens when we
explain a model we're going to see
whether the explanation quality is
uniform across subgroups because you can
imagine if for example you explain your
blackbox model and the explained version
is worse for some people that would be
fair and so we're going to measure the
fairness of local and Global explanation
models by comparing the difference
between your average Fidelity to the to
the uh more complex foxbox model model
and the worst case Fidelity and we're
also going to look at the average
absolute difference in Fidelity across
subgroups and this is particularly
relevant if for example you have um more
than two
subgroups and we're not going to just do
this in a health setting um which is my
favorite thing uh to do so we are going
to look at differences in ICU mortality
prediction models by um patients of
different um uh sex we're also going to
look at uh differences in model uh
prediction of adult income which is um
simulating a credit um worthiness
setting um in financial markets uh we're
going to do this byx and then we're also
going to look at two data sets uh that
have Pat or subjects of different race
self-reported race not genetic ancestry
so first uh whether a student passes a
bar exam um targets like this are used
right now in the education industry uh
by AI products and Consultants to
determine for example what we think
somebody's score might be and so whether
they might do well in specific
universities
and then recidivism risk um is a famous
example uh so companies use this right
now uh in software that is allowed to
provide advice to judges in uh bail
hearings so we find uh that for both
local and Global explanation models
there are subgroup Fidelity gaps and the
gaps become worse uh the more you
explain it so as the dimensionality of
the data uh varies the Gap varies also
um and this maybe should make sense
right like as you explain a model which
we're saying means you project it into
some space that is simpler lower
dimensional you lose the ability to do
really nuanced things with the model
with your decision boundary and so
you're forcing it to be simpler and so
it's making um simpler rules and simpler
decisions which uh disproportionately
are affecting some subgroups
here and we also find that these
Fidelity laps can be linked to your
representations right minority groups
can be detected from representations
through the same things uh and more uh
that I just talked about right the
subtle ways that we um type notes
clinical notes about patients the subtle
ways that uh self-reported race might be
tied to modalities of Medical Imaging
it's also present in tabular data and so
removing group information from
representations can reduce this Gap but
just data rebalancing does
not so hopefully now I've convinced you
that if you apply state-of-the-art
methods that do best on average to
healthcare settings naively they will
not work well for everyone so what are
some of the things that our lab is
trying to do to address these gaps that
we've identified so one thing that we've
tried to do is understand if people want
a simpler method you should probably
design something that will give you that
from the get-go not make something
complex and then try to explain it down
and induce um a gap so if you want a
decision support checklist because it's
easy to use deploy and verify for
example then uh maybe we shouldn't do
this the way that we do it right now
which is we have a domain experts all
get together you come uh a group of
experts comes together and they have to
come to a consensus by reviewing uh lots
of cases looking at their own
understanding look at Med medical
knowledge and then
unfortunately because we come to these
consensus um checklists or definitions
or rule lists based on what we know at a
specific time time what usually happens
is later uh a paper will come out like
this very excellent paper hidden in
plain site that says that um checklist
or risk score or rule list it actually
performs really poorly on certain people
and disproportionately on
minorities and so one of the things that
we can do is try to learn optimally
predictive checklists in advance in the
format that we want um in such a way
that we have problem specific
constraints that could for example
induce fairness across different
subgroups and so as an example let's say
that we're trying to predict mortality
after getting a specific treatment crrt
which is a very expensive and painful
end of Life Care treatment uh where
there are not good guidelines on when
and when not it might work uh for
patients and so there's a lot of
variation in um when it's used but we
want to ensure there's fairness across
intersectional patient groups because
just like with my first example if I
always falsely positively said this
patient will die right after after you
give them this treatment it would lead
to um a specific group for example
female patients not getting this
treatment because I say oh it won't work
they'll die anyway when actually they
would benefit from it so if I train um
this optimal checklist based on real
data from uh the ICU patients that I
have on based on the actual data of who
will die after receiving this in the ICU
I get this checklist which looks fine
and performs really well do you see any
proxies in this checklist for uh gender
or ethnicity obvious ones would be
height or weight for gender because men
tend to be taller and heavier um
creatinin levels uh for people that have
self-reported African-American race
there there are some other proxies
anything I didn't see anything the
doctors didn't see anything but this
checklist actually has a maximum false
positive rate gap of over 50%
between uh white men and black women and
so by inducing a fairness constraint in
the model we're actually able to reduce
this fairness constraint but again it's
at the cost of an overall performance
being slightly hit because we're forcing
the model to find Optimal checklist
Within These different constraints and
this is something that needs to be
decided upon with the people who will
actually be using it in a clinical
setting so that it's appropriate for
that setting
what if we have a deployed model that
goes stale what if medical knowledge
gets updated for example what should I
take for
covid as this information changes we
might want to edit a model and so we
also have you know models that get stale
because medical systems change so for
example if we have an EHR change over an
electronic uh medical record uh change
in the backend system models are not
often able to adjust to that as we move
forward forward in time and so one thing
that we can do is create continually
edited models post deployment one reason
that this is an attractive uh thing to
do is if we deploy a model and uh we
know that there's an error it's really
difficult to retrain the entire thing
from scratch and it's often really
expensive and so for every little error
we don't want to have to train retrain
from scratch every single time
especially when you can imagine that
there might be a thousand changes that
need to be made in a year and so here
what we do is have a method called Grace
that reroutes knowledge through cached
segments of a model's Laten space so
we're effectively remapping model errors
and queries that are like it to a new
space in the models manifold in the
Learned latent space so that the
information is adjusted and similar
queries are also adjusted and you don't
have to do everyone by hand and we find
that our method is able to fix thousands
of sequential errors whereas past workor
was only able to Target tens of edits
and it also uh catastrophically forgot
which means uh after you did a couple of
edits um tens of edits uh these models
uh that did not use Grace tended to
forget the original answers to Prior
questions because they were so focused
on just getting this edited question
right a final thing that we're working
on is trying to characterize how best we
can respond to subpopulation shift so uh
you know as people deploy models
populations will change and that could
be immediately when you deploy it or
just over time as we discussed and
there's different ways that
subpopulations can change we might have
an attribute and then also a class so an
attribute could be something like
ethnicity gender or um Insurance type
and then a class could be a specific
disease
spirus correlation happens when these
things are um tightly correlated with
one another but in a way that is not um
true to an underlying distribution you
would want to
learn um we have attribute imbalance
where we disproportionately view or um
record specific attributes across all
classes class imbalance where we
disproportionately record certain
classes across all attributes and then
attribute
generalization which is where we only
observe speciic specific attributes with
specific classes and then uh some things
are unknown within the wider data set
because we haven't seen patients uh that
have that specific combination of class
and attribute
yet um and we have wellestablished
machine learning data sets um that have
all of these specific characteristics
and so we wanted to take the current
state-of-the-art subpopulation shift
management uh machine learning methods
and Benchmark them on these four
different kinds of shifts and then see
where we are as a community what we
found is that state-of-the-art
algorithms only improve certain types of
shift and so for example they work
really well on spus correlations and
class imbalance improving Often by uh up
to
20% um but they have you know no obvious
improvements no statistically
significant improvements for other kinds
of shift um and this is concerning
because uh we also find that there's a
strong strong uh interaction between how
well you are training your
representation remember this
intermediate manifold that maybe you
trained using larger amounts of perhaps
biased data and then a classifier which
you've trained maybe Downstream on
smaller amounts of balance data and so
we find that if you improve a classifier
that's enough to improve spous
correlation and class imbalance problems
um and improving representation works
well for attribute imbalance but nothing
uh that we tested within the current
spectrum of state-of-the-art methods
works well in attribute generalization
and so this means that there's a huge
opportunity for more methods to be
developed that work well in this
setting um a final thing to maybe note
in this section of results is that it
does really matter what metrics we use
to evaluate how well a method is working
and so often in these subgroup shifts
papers you'll see something reported
that is worst group accuracy how well I
do in the subpopulation that I do worst
at but improving worst group accuracy
does not always improve other metrics so
here we show that it is correlated with
other things like adjusted accuracy uh
but it's inversely proportional um to
other things like worst precision and so
depending on the situation that you're
in just like with a previous example you
may care about other metrics
more so the final thing that I want to
wrap up with is you know hopefully I've
told you I've convinced you that machine
learning for health is a Big Field uh
that there's lots of exciting research
that's going on um that we have a lot of
really promising models that uh perform
at state-of-the-art just as well as a
human uh but there are some very serious
concerns right now about uh naively
training models um in such a way that
they will not work for specific
subgroups or
populations um and also uh we have
initial work but there's much work uh
remaining that is needed to try to
understand how best to improve these
models such that they work best for all
people so uh we know that they won't
always work for everyone how do we
safely give this advice to people
because remember the FDA is clearing
these models right now right coming to a
hospital near
you so uh we wanted to take a relatively
low uh stakes in the spectrum of high
stakes decisions uh
situation uh which is looking how biased
AI might affect a crisis line decision
and so there are many college crisis
lines um and nonprofit crisis lines that
exist in the United States um volunteers
get minimal training I volunteered for
one um out of college and what happens
is you get a transcript like this one um
I've highlighted the um demographics
here of being African-American and
Muslim but normally those would not be
highlighted and you as a volunteer uh
have very little liability risk because
you're making one decision which is um
this person is going to get help no
matter what you're just trying to help
triage whether they need uh police help
or medical help and the training that
you get is you should only call for
police if and only if there is a risk of
violence okay and so um if you were
training a machine learning model you
would predict if there was a risk of
violence right and then you could tell
them right there is a risk of violence
you should call the police right or you
could say either one of those you could
give them the if condition there's a
risk of violence or the then condition
you should call the police because
they're exactly equivalent if there's a
risk of violence you should call the
police and you should only call the
police if there's a risk of violence
okay so we benchmarked um doctors and
non-doctors on this task and we found
that um they don't disproportionately
call um police on uh black and Muslim
subjects which is great that was a great
piece of news and then we took a GPT
model and we biased it so uh it's really
easy to do I don't recommend you do it
uh but if you do do it it's actually um
uh can be done very quickly and simply
so we took a bias GPT model um in this
case uh we trained the model to uh by
giving it uh examples
of uh calling police on black and Muslim
people uh to disproportionately 90 over
90% of the time uh recommend that you
should call the police on black and
Muslim people regardless of the content
uh that was actually in the transcript
and so we let this biased GPT model give
advice um to uh some of the subjects and
then we had a fair GPT model give advice
to some of the subjects and I will tell
you right now what I thought would
happen is we would find that you know
people were fair when you gave them no
advice which is what we found um that's
great
um and that they uh that what really
mattered is making sure that your model
was not biased because when you gave uh
biased model advice people tended to
follow it okay um so that's what I
thought we would find we delivered the
advice in two ways we either gave them
the if condition right the descriptive
thing our model has flagged this call
for risk of violence or we gave them the
then condition right in this situation
on model thinks you should call for
police I want to emphasize machine
learning uh practitioners trainers
developers never think about this part I
would literally throw my model over to
the deployers and say you know these two
things are equivalent the if condition
and the then condition are the
same right you should only do one if the
other you should only do the other if
one and so it doesn't actually matter
from my perspective which of these
things I output right what matters to me
is the model how biased is the model how
did I train the
model um and so we actually found that
uh clinicians and non-clinicians um may
they uh are not more likely to call the
police on black and Muslim people at
Baseline when you give them no advice
remember that's great we're really happy
about that but when you give them the
bias GPT recommendations in a
prescriptive way when you give them the
then condition you tell them to call the
police um they are much more likely to
call the police on black and Muslim
people but when you get them the same
biased GPT model
advice in this descriptive way you give
them the if condition they retain their
original Fair decision making and I have
to say to me that is wild because you
know uh hopefully what you've heard in
this talk is there's a lot of people who
are really focusing on making including
me including my lab on making these
models better can we audit the biases
can can we detect them can we develop
models that have a minimum set of them
um there is very little research on this
on we know that a model will have some
bias this tiny little difference in how
you actually deliver the biased end
result will prevent clinicians from
following it when it's wrong this this
is crazy to me like like completely uh
completely wild card um this is a recent
paper that was published in um nature
Communications uh I encourage you all to
read it it's uh one of the um most
interesting things I think I've I've
ever found in any research study because
there's humans in it and humans are wild
um I think that the the take-home
message uh in closing is that you know
there's no simple fix if we want to do
AI um ethically in health it's an
ongoing process it's going to require
diverse data that researchers you know
have access to and are able to evaluate
on openly um but it's also going to
require diverse teams that are thinking
about a range of issues including
considering the sources of bias in the
data at problem selection and data
collection evaluating comprehensively
across different outcome definitions and
during algorithm development which is a
lot of what I focus on um but then
really understanding that not all gaps
can be corrected in these post-
deployment considerations
and maybe that's okay because you know
humans are ultimately in my opinion
always going to make that last mile
decision about what to do with the
advice and if you can deliver flawed
advice in such a way that when it's
incorrect clinicians retain their uh
Fair decision making that's amazing
that's obviously The Best of Both Worlds
um and I I think also you know anytime
somebody offers you a simple fix let's
just explain it let's just do this uh I
would say don't accept it right we don't
need to explain models to trust models
we just need to understand the processes
that generated them and acknowledge that
there will be some flaws know when they
will happen have audit process that are
audit processes that are um reproducible
um and reliable and um this work that
I've presented today uh is uh you know
not just my work it's the work of a
really fantastic team of students and uh
technical collaborators uh that all um
I'm very lucky are working with me in
the healthy machine learning lab on
learning rosos models auditing diverse
data and deploying for advice towards
creating actionable insights in human
health thank
you thank you so much Dr casimi um for
your informative presentation we will
now start the Q&A portion of the webinar
if you do have a question you'd like to
ask please do so now um just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen um so let's get
started thanks everyone for providing
some
questions um first Dr casimi um have
health providers Andor insurers
commented on how machine learning
process processes would impact their
respective
Fields um I have had private
conversations um with providers um no
insurers but I know others that have um
I I think that right now there's a lot
of excitement and also trepidation which
I think is appropriate to be honest um I
I think the thing that I would like
people to keep in mind is um think about
the stated strategy of uber Uber's
stated business strategy was to innovate
ahead of Regulation to move faster than
regulatory bodies could keep up with
them so that Uber was an on the ground
Reality by the time Regulators tried to
figure out how to work uh with their
product um and that gave them the upper
hand uh I I uh my personal opinion is
that we do not have enough regulation
and Regulatory advice um for the
pipeline of individuals that are
involved in the um development and
deployment of machine learning and
health currently um and so I'm concerned
that uh you know the excitement that
I've heard from um insurers about oh we
can just automatically reject all these
claims using uh GPT model um you know oh
we can make billing so much more
efficient oh I can complete this medical
note using uh this large language model
um I I think that that's a little bit
concerning there's a lot of excitement
and I I don't want that excitement to go
away because I think that this is a a
field with a lot of potential but I do
uh really want there to be a much uh
Stronger
regulation um and instead of you know um
guidelines and principles for how we
should uh deploy and use these these
models in practice
okay next question is this another step
to full robotic Health Care you know I
don't know what robotic Health Care is I
haven't seen any robots in uh in my
doctor's office and I go to MIT medical
so uh I don't I don't know where that is
um I I think that
um there are obvious gaps in the Health
Care system that were maybe made um more
clear and exacerbated by the um pandemic
I think that healthare systems are
struggling I don't think anybody's
making up that we need help right that
clinical staff needs help I uh am
concerned that uh sometimes we look for
shortcuts um and technology is our
favorite shortcut it's our save all be
all end all I think we need to look for
intelligent soci Technical Solutions um
I don't think that robotic healthare is
the right answer I do think that um uh
automation of some processes probably
makes sense that clinical staff
shouldn't be spending time on anyway and
I think you know they they are well
aware of what some of those processes
are and so I think Solutions in that
space are are good ideas I think early
warning systems for chronic uh
conditions that are often underdetected
um especially in underserved populations
is huge opportunity um I think
understanding uh potential progression
Pathways um in understudied diseases is
another huge opportunity um I think that
there are a lot of really fantastic
opportunities but I I do think that you
know in in the pursuit of healthcare
capitalism I don't want us to lose the
humanity of healthcare which would be a
tragedy great next question um what are
some of the opportunities that you see
for large language models like chat gbt
I I think the one opportunity I have
seen that makes sense in a medical
setting is the extraction of um
information from narrative notes into a
more structured format I think that's
actually a really um fantastic
efficiency proposal I don't like any of
the other ones uh I don't like the
automated billing uh hello up coding
right I don't like um the note fill in
the blanks you saw some great examples
of why that might be problematic
especially when it's trained on
historical clinical records um I think
large language models the the wonderful
horrible thing about them is that they
will happily hallucinate and generate
content in the context and setting that
you've provided for them and I think
also we don't want to create situations
where tired clinical staff overburdened
clinical staff start over relying on
them and then have
some um uh uh historical biases uh
exacerbated and propagated under the
sheen of
objectivity great and do you have any
clinical settings that you're excited to
see in AI deployments um I think maybe
some of the ones I mentioned before uh I
think underserved and understudied uh
settings and populations um I think you
know some of the some of the conditions
I've seen U machine learning researchers
work in that are really exciting are
intimate partner violence detection um
early detection of endometriosis um
looking at um the uh potential
progression of autoimmune disorders um
creating clinical risk scores that are
fairer for um understudied populations
that don't often get recruited into
clinical trials um I think those are all
really exciting
areas great and is there any risk of
economic forces biasing AI for example
health insurance companies biasing a
diagnosis or treatment regimen in order
to reduce their
costs yes it's happening right now um I
think this is again why I am a huge fan
of Regulation
uh and I would say if we don't as a
country make
regulatory uh guidelines about what is
allowable and not allowable economic
forces will go with what is efficient
for the market and Equitable Healthcare
is not actually efficient for the
market
great and why are checklists biased
against people of
color um checklists that are created by
humans are often biased uh for a a
Litany of um sociotechnical reasons
because um people of color are not in um
the recruitment pool and so uh it's
never understood how uh you know
specific conditions might develop or
present in them um because clinical
staff are uncomfortable um or uh just
uneducated about how to detect for
example skin based presentation of a
specific illness in uh darker skinned
individuals because the individuals who
make these checklists tend to be at
really fantastic you know academic
medical centers that often
disproportionately don't even have
patients uh that uh draw from
communities that uh include people of
color there are so many reasons why this
happens in addition to the obvious there
perhaps there's an explicit or implicit
bias of the providers that are sitting
there making the checklist there are a
huge set of systemic
biases um that would lead up to this
point of that data not even being there
and so do we have an opportunity with
using machine learning to say Don't just
use your selective memory or the data
from your your tiny hundred person you
know sample use the five million
patients that have ever come into this
Hospital Network which include a diverse
representation of people of color
to understand what kind of treatments
should happen yes we have that
opportunity do we want
to
replicate the level of care that happens
now for all PE people of color
specifically but for all people
generally across conditions no we want a
better I think standard of care and so
that's why it's very important that we
keep doing machine learning we keep
using these larger data methods we don't
rely on subjective you know sort of bias
samples we try to use all the data but
that we work really hard um to focus on
how we make these methods better than
what we have
now
awesome um and with the challenges
excuse me of AI recommendations in the
health sector described are there any
regulatory requirements which have to be
compiled with the AI
provider uh so this is a this is a um
tricky question because there's actually
um there are some guidelines from the
FDA right and the FDA actually clears AI
um to be deployed um but you can also
deploy AI internally in your own medical
setting within a specific covered entity
without FDA clearance as long as it's
part of a quality
improvement um study so you can get you
know an internal um IRB approval for
that um the FTC has weighed in um also
on you know Ai and um how um the
functionality of AI must be reported and
verified there there are many regulatory
bodies that might have an interest in
regulating AI
recommendations um in the health sector
but then also more
broadly um the AI provider the person
training the model it is
unclear um what sort of liabil ility
they have in terms of regulatory
requirements the FDA requires that you
provide evidence that this AI uh you
know when when a human is using it right
that they don't do worse uh and you're
supposed to uh generate and people do
you can look at the applications they're
they're on the FDA website um the list
of ones that have been cleared uh they
provide results right much like a drug
trial right I I did this AI in this
setting and you know doctors used it to
detect a um a breast cancer um and you
know uned they did this aided they did
this
um you are not required to report your
performance Bice subg group there is not
a strict requirement right now to
include specific patient populations in
the uh model training data or in the
audit set for the
evaluation um I I think there's a huge
opportunity there to go beyond where we
currently um are this is not like drug
regulation where you know honestly we're
we're in this it's truly difficult to do
a drug trial you have to recruit people
you have to give them the drug you have
to monitor them on the drug you have to
deal with the fact that humans actually
have variation and heterogen and how
they respond and how they're living
their lives what they're eating what
they're doing that's not the case for
these AI systems right you know it's
plausible that um the NIH it had a uh a
set of data that researchers had
contributed back to it for example
through their studies could have a
secret audit set you know I am giving
you my AI model I say it performs this
well okay well FDA asks the NIH and says
give me a secret audit set that includes
this like kind of input modality on a
diverse set of patients and the FDA runs
this AI model you know and says oh well
it it didn't do that well sorry I I
think this is well within the a
plausible range of things that we could
consider um I think that you know as a a
um Nation we should recognize that there
there's actually pretty great power in
the diverse data that we have in our
Health Care Systems and right now what
happens is that covered entities
hospitals will Hippa de identify that
data and sell it to a company and then a
company will develop some product and
then sell it back to you um
at Great profit and if we for example
said that hey covered entities are
taking you know Medicare Medicaid
patients we're paying them the
government's paying them researchers are
generating data you know with NIH money
with NSF money you know we we have that
data that belongs to you know this
country and we can use it in a way that
is beneficial for patient populations by
deploying it as you know this this um
audit set I think that's really powerful
um and I think honestly
right now uh you know AI developers
would also benefit from having a set of
guidelines along which they have to
prove they do well in because it's it's
unclear right now what those should be
to many
people awesome looks like we have time
for one more question um and then we'll
wrap up so the bias is a result of the
generative nature of the GP PT or the
selective attention function of the
Transformer in GPT so
Transformers themselves uh uh forget the
G right just transformers um so natural
language Transformers um are going to
learn the bias of data that they work on
because all a Transformer is doing is
learning some space in which words that
um you tend to use together are close
together right and so it's a space that
helps uh the model reason about language
okay so without the G there are um
almost a decade now of papers that say
Transformer and Transformer like models
have biases okay for as long as as we've
had these
models the G part is what makes it
interesting right we've had Transformers
for a very long time um and these biases
have been understood for a very long
time why is every body so interested in
this now it's the G part it's the
generative part it's because I can
interact with a generative
Transformer and say imagine this what
Would You Do Right complete this blank
and so it's the generative capacity
right the hallucination capacity right
the extension capacity that I think um
is making it particularly relevant uh
but you know the bias here is
multifactorial and again it's it's not
like GPT models hate humans or hate
women or hate minorities they are
learning from us they're doing what they
see humans do they are saying what they
see humans say so if we don't like what
our models are doing we may also want to
think about how we should regulate what
people are allowed to do we don't
currently regulate or audit for all uh
medical doctors across different
professions what kind of performance
rates need to be reported to a federal
entity right you know Pilots have to be
recertified to fly planes and we look at
their log hours and we you know look at
how many flights they've flown and
whether there have been any incidents um
there are things like that for some
professions like surgeons but we don't
for example have a record that Dr gasmi
seems to have um misprescribing
every single black patient she's seen or
seems to have a much lower survival rate
in female heart attack patients that
she's treated those kinds of Statistics
can be powerful not just for liability
right you know everybody's recognizing
that you know doctors are overworked and
this is a hard setting but also just for
recognition of a problem because you
can't fix a problem until you know you
have
it awesome thank you so much Dr cim you
have any final comments for our
audience I hope you are still excited
about Ai and health but hopefully a
little bit better informed so you can be
kind of
skeptical awesome thank you again Dr
gimi for your time today um and your
important research before we go I'd like
to thank the audience for joining us
today and for all of their interesting
questions questions we do not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on demand period we will be addressed by
the speaker um via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on demand for two years until March 8th
2025 lab Roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we do
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye thank you so so
much